done and what may not be apparent till
you see it up close the upper-body
strength of LeBron is a physical
specialist 11 it's gonna be a third foul
charged to Dedmon so he gives way to
Alex Len Bradley Beal piling up the
points he now has 16 he became the
Wizards career leader in three-pointers
made Brett Lee bill is the guy that 16
[Applause]
give it up to the fans for the
[Applause]
presented it to him at the game LeBron
James didn't play because he didn't play
in the first one than when they played
in Golden State
ladies out of anybody they're gonna make
that call all day long so you've got to
be able to stop when the offensive
player goes in the air just like
anything including the hidden just
typical jump shot Chris they've got to
have the freedom to come down clinging
and already in the lip Kawhi Leonard
two-time all-star
two-time Defensive Player of the Year
2014 NBA Finals MVP foul by fours and
we'll go to the ladder for the couple
try to pick up my water trailer
amazing how they can do that in unison
yeah yeah one section gets it going you
hear one guy say well that's a good one
let me have two
[Applause]
when I get in the business here tonight
he is
time to check the ball let's took a look
at ents up cutting
[Applause]
and sons continue to struggle from the
free-throw line now 4 of 9
yeah just don't expect it from this guy
in particular and when you look at Kelly
who plays numbers
Allen will get brown
Johnson
sure you can tell is being chanted by
the crowd right now we walked I read in
bed line approaches in fact was not
guaranteed until sometime this month
plans not effective second Machat
during a nice chill Center for minute
Raymond Felton Raymond Felton ETSU the
campi Paul George is joined again but
he's got to hit the glass I really do I
think one of the things you can do
against the Lakers because you can all
fit some rebound them but most
importantly you have to transition back
for defensive purposes the forced him to
play through your defense Brandon Ingram
in his third year to do the average 16
points last year in year two is at 17 22
his last five he's averaging 23 points
per game with all of the rumors of the
speculation that's been swirling around
the Lakers the last week with Anthony
day